Hey guys, and welcome to episode number
five of my GE only challenge. Uh you may
notice that the map has been changed a
little bit uh since the last episode. Uh
so I'll come and explain why. Uh so
first off, I've added the Verac sewer
system. This will be unlocked at 750
total level. Uh which will equate to
about late 40 early 50s in all of my
skills. Uh reasonably challenging. Uh
and the reason I added that is just to
get um well a couple extra areas and
monsters to train on. Uh, and I don't
think it's going to impact the series
too much. And it's nice to have a little
bit more content for combat related
things for later. And uh, the extra
other zone we added was the Kelliggram
mine uh, which will be unlocked at 1,000
total level, which is about 60 to 70s in
most of my skills. Uh, because I think
there's 16 or 17 skills I can train
right now. Uh, that's including
smithing, that's including um, prayer as
all of them combined. So, it's going to
be pretty challenging to reach that. But
I think Calgram can offer a couple extra
uh perks to this challenge that
otherwise wouldn't be there, including
mining training. Um there's brewing. I
mean, it's just kind of a cool area and
it's really connected to the Grand
Exchange. So, uh what do you guys think
about these changes? Do you like them?
Um please leave a comment or any
suggestion for anything else I could add
later on. Although, I am not planning on
really expanding any more than this. Uh
but you never know. Uh for now, these
goals are pretty long-term. Uh so, it'll
take a while to hit them. And yeah,
thanks again for all your support and
let's get started. Okay, so we're going
to start off by just checking on our
flips. Uh now, we did flip a super
energy potion by decanting them. We made
I guess 50 can it, which is pretty good.
Uh was a little expensive, but we'll go
ahead and put another offer in for
those. Uh we'll slowly probably flip all
2,000, which is the buying limit,
because they're coming through really
quickly. On top of that, we are training
our fletching, which we again slowly
working our way up there. We're on to
the maple shoro right now, and let's see
how much experience we can get. Okay,
we're just about to hit a fletching
level. Uh, going really quickly. Uh, 55
fletching, which is pretty awesome. Uh,
now we can make broad bolts, I guess, if
we wanted. Uh, really good experience
for broadbolts, but terrible money.
You're losing 100% of your money. So,
I'm not sure if we're going to do that
ever, but anyway, we can do it when we
want. Okay, because the price of the
maple logs was so cheap, uh, we can
actually sell off all the maple short
bows pretty much instantly for a profit
of about 100k, I believe. Not sure if
we'll have it in our grand exchange
history here, but anyway, we sold them
for 338K. So, I think we're going to
bank uh this is going to be from 55 to
65, I believe. We're going to do maple
long bows and we're going to need about
4,000. And now, we can't afford to buy
this and the bow strings right now. But,
I think we'll bank all of the maple long
bows unstrung and we'll get to them
eventually. But, it is still a 500k
investment here. So, I'm not sure. We
may end up selling these back, but for
now, that'll be enough to get to level
65. Okay, we're just about to hit a
defense level. Uh there is 30 defense.
So now we can wear I guess it's adamant
armor which will be kind of nice. Uh but
also more importantly uh we can wear our
snake skin armor which will actually
increase our damage a little bit
hopefully or at least our accuracy
anyway. Okay so we sold off these
skeletal gloves uh we had bought for
let's see 65k. So that's a really good
flip. 60k on the skeletal gloves was
pretty lengthy though. Uh but not too
bad. We'll go ahead and buy another one
of these. A pretty good item. Okay so we
bought a bunch of snakes skin armor. So,
this should uh increase our range bonus
uh by decently um because we did not
have any ranging boots. Uh which is
nice. So, oh, we have me gear on. Okay,
so our range bonus is 79, but then we're
going to equip the snake skin. 81 snakes
skin boots will help out a lot. Well,
one, never mind. Uh snake skin and um
that's not as good as I thought it was
going to be, but 84 still a noticeable
difference anyway. And uh we can also
use a rune axe now. I just realized our
wood cutting has been 40 for a little
while now. But yeah, we'll go buy a rune
axe and I think we might do a little
wood cutting as well. I'm not sure why,
but I've always been a fan of wood
cutting. Uh, and especially right now,
my hands have been hurting quite a bit.
Uh, not from really playing Runescape,
but just from a lot of different things.
Uh, and wood cutting is pretty chill.
So, we're just about to hit 45 wood
cutting, I believe. And, uh, well, only
15 more levels, so we can chop you
trees. Although, I don't think it's
going to be very effective then either,
but h well, we can always hope. Is this
going to be enough to get the level?
There it is. 45 wood cutting. Uh, still
going pretty quick with the oak trees.
We're getting about almost 30k an hour,
which is not too bad. Okay, so we got
some blips coming in. Uh, the obsidian
item, I don't actually remember what we
bought it for. I think we did profit a
bit off this, but um, probably not too
noticeable, or I would have remembered
it, I guess. The skeletal gloves, uh, we
sold for 100k and bought them for 65k,
so it's a 35k profit there. And the
super energies, we're making about 50 or
60k on each. Uh, see, we uh flip. We
bought them for 1,5 and we're selling
them for uh 1,65. So, yeah, pretty much
50k on each one, which is pretty good.
Uh, so what we're going to be doing now
is buying uh individual pages and
combining them into uh page sets. So,
what we're doing it right now with is
the ancient page. Uh, looked pretty
good. We have it open on GE Tracker. It
shows us a couple different page sets
that we can do. Now, we're going to be
able to afford two of these, just
barely. Uh, so we're going to be turning
these into the book of darkness page
sets. And uh, we actually instantly
bought one of the pages here. But
basically what I'm doing is I'm just
going through all the items on G
Tracker, just finding the rough low
point of the item. Uh, put an offer in
for that. And then once we have the
items, we'll combine them into page sets
and resell them. Uh, we should be
getting about uh, 80 to 100k per set
combination. Uh, so we're looking to
make 150 160k off this. Uh, and uh, when
you have more money and you can buy the
full bind limits worth, which is five,
uh, you can make actually I made 600k on
one of these recently on my main
account. Uh, so yeah, pretty good. Okay,
so I think all the pages have come
through. Uh, now looks like, yeah, two
of each. Uh, which is awesome. So, I'll
just show you once how I combine them.
It's really easy. So, just go to the
Grand Exchange Clerk, go under sets, if
you can click it anyway, and then you
just have to go find the set and just
click it once. There it is. Boom. and
it'll pack up all the books instantly
right there. Uh, so that's very
convenient. If you can leave an offer
like this in overnight, it can be really
effective because you then kind of help
circumvent the buying limit. Uh, but
yeah, we're going to be selling them for
I think about 1225 which is going to get
us about 75 uh 200k depending on what
the can sell it for anyway. All right.
So, we'd be selling them for 2450 minus
630 for the page one, 620 for the page
two. Uh 668 for the page three, and um
420 for the page two. Uh only 112k, so
this isn't the best one by any means,
but it was cheap and we can do it. Okay,
I think we're actually about to hit
another farming level. Uh pretty slow,
but we are chugging along here. We're
getting I think we need probably still
275 to 300 of these rakes left to do. I
think realistically we're going to hit
the cash amount to buy construction
which inherently will give us access to
farming. But um my god, this takes so
long sometimes. Anyway, there's level
five farming with a milestone. Only uh
seven more levels to get our farming
patch unlocked. Okay, so the page sets
finally sold off. They took a long time.
I'm not really sure why most people are
not buying the page sets for this for
whatever reason. It just took a long
time and we didn't make nearly as much
as we thought we were going to. Probably
only 70k on the full flip and we're
going to calculate it quickly. So yeah,
this is a little underwhelming. It works
better with uh the Zamre page size, but
only 40k. So that's not very good. Okay,
so we're going to move on to some other
items to flip. Uh the holy blessing
seems pretty good. Uh has about a 12 or
15k margin. An item this cheap is really
good. So, we're going to do 10. Mind
you, I think the limit was actually
five. So, this is a bit of a mistake on
my part. Next up, we're going to do the
war blessing, which is 11k into 22k. Uh,
very good for the amount. Um, I guess
it's this high because the limit is so
low, but anyway, for someone with a 50k
cash tag, this is a really good item.
I'm going to be doubling my money. 20
and 30 is definitely a mistake. We're
not going to be able to buy that many,
but oh well. So, it looks like the
energy potion actually has a 43gp margin
per potion decanted. Uh, which is
awesome. We're going to make about 90k
off of these 2,000 potions, which is
great. And we got a war blessing coming
through. Awesome. Uh, the super attack
potion, really cheap, but working really
well. Once again, 255US 185 is a massive
margin for super attacks. We're going to
get 140k off this. Uh, that's really
good. Um, it's only going to be a 300k
investment. Uh, so that's amazing. And
last up, we're going to put an offer in
for an Odium Shard one. Now, I'm a
little wary of this item because almost
no one buys this. People will sell it
because they get it as a monster drop,
but I've had some issues selling this
item in the past, but we're going to get
it give it another try. Put an offer in
for 715 and just hope we can sell it.
Okay, so the wood cutting experience is
flying by. Uh we have been playing
Smarstone and wood cutting. It's kind of
easy to do them both at the same time.
And we're actually getting quite a few
bird birds nests. Uh we got a palm tree
seed as well, which is worth 60k. And uh
we'll see what's in this other bird's
nest. A willow seed. That's about 12k as
well. So I should probably getting 50 or
60k an hour doing this. Okay, so all our
flips are back and we profited on
everything except for the odium shard
one. Uh which we did lose money on. I'm
never going to do that again. I don't
think just took a long time. I had to
sell that thing off. Uh so to start off,
we sold the holy blessings for 265k and
we bought them for 190. So it's a 75k
profit there. Really good. Uh the war
blessing we sold for I think 115k and we
bought it for 60 uh which is pretty
good. 105 actually uh so that's only
well about 45k 50k profit. Pretty good
for the cost. Uh the super energy
potions we bought for uh 613k I believe
and uh we sold those for 741. And these
super attack potions we bought for only
191 and sold them for 268 on just 750
potions. So 70 70k profit there just off
that many potions is crazy. Uh so I
think we're going to go do the energy
potions once again. Uh they've just been
working so well and very cost effective
for their well cost. Uh so I'll put
another 2k potions in for energies. So
it looks like the margin on super attack
potions is still extremely good at 61 GP
per potion. Uh, so we'll do another
2,000 of those happily. Okay, so next up
we're looking at the Verox Helm, which
uh 243 to 270 is pretty good for how
quickly this item is going to trade.
Now, since I know the price of this is
probably fluctuating more than the graph
because there's uh three or 400 traded a
day, there's no way that's going to be
accurate. We are just going to straight
up price check this item. Uh, so we
bought it for 280 and we're going to
sell it for
uh 270. We'll still do it. It's a 10k
profit, which isn't extreme by any
means, but still pretty good. And we'll
do well, I'll do six maybe. Okay, so you
know how I mentioned earlier that the
page combination works better with Zami
pages? Now, we've done this and we
literally instabbought every single page
uh because I was going off to G Tracker
prices and for whatever reason, every
piece of the page cost has dropped
pretty severely. Uh so hopefully the
whole book isn't crashing. So, we just
combined it and uh at these prices,
we're looking to make 200K off of the
book. So yeah, you can see here 2424 is
what we're hoping to sell it for. And
I'm pretty sure the cost of the pages
were only like 2,50 or 2100. Uh so yeah,
we're poised to make quite a bit off of
this flip now. I don't know because the
actively trade price has dropped, but
we'll give it a try. Yeah, 350k it looks
like. I just did the math. So very good.
Okay, we just hit a hit points level.
That is 40 hit points. Bit of a
milestone there. We're back to training
our range. We're going to go for 50
range hopefully pretty soon. And another
mysterious mana random. I feel like I
get these a lot more frequently now. And
they're not actually that useful. I
really want the fishing random cuz
that'll get actually us from level one
to seven fishing just off that random
event. All right. 53 death runes from
that. Actually, your best one yet.
Pretty well. But still, it's okay, I
guess. Okay. We're just about to hit
another range level, which is going to
be another milestone, which is 45 range.
Uh we're getting probably the close to
the top experience we're going to get at
these guards. So I'm not going to level
up my range too much past 50 because
once we get 750 total we'll have access
to mosh giants will be much more
effective to train and uh we're actually
going to get a farming level too. That's
assuming that we can rake the patch
which sometimes look how ridiculously
long this takes. Uh okay I guess I'll
cut the clip. Oh my god. There we go.
Finally six farming. Another total level
we can add to our total. at about 467 so
far. So, I think it's about time that we
train our crafting up a bit more. Uh,
and I just realized that if I get my
crafting to I think 33, I can actually
start uh glass blowing uh I think
fishbowls, which actually are going to
be cheaper than making leather chaps.
Even though they're roughly the same
experience per hour, uh the molten glass
only cost about 120 or 130, where the uh
leather cost more than 200, I believe.
So, we're going to go for 33 for now.
Okay. Okay. And those leather traps are
pretty good, but there's 33 crafting we
can now or sorry, it's vials we can
make. Uh the fish bowls are later on,
but for now we can just make vials.
Worthless, but uh still cheaper. Okay,
there is level 38 crafting. Uh just
crafting vials right now. Uh pretty
quick experience. We're getting about
55k and we also hit a total level of
475. Another small milestone. All right,
we're just about put another crafting
level uh which is going to be level 40
crafting. And I think we can craft uh
ruby necklaces now, which is okay if we
actually ever wanted to do that. Uh
still on the vials, but I think at 43 or
something, we get fishbowls. Uh which
will be even quicker experience. Okay,
there we go. Another crafting level.
That is going to be 42 crafting, and
that will be enough to make fishbowls.
Uh that should increase our experience
per hour by another 15k per hour,
roughly. Unfortunately, no one wants the
fishbowls. I don't think they're even
more worthless than the vials, I think.
All right, I think this should be the
last inventory of fishbowls. 43
experience a pop. Uh 42 and a2. I guess
there is 46 crafting. Now we can craft
orbs. Uh which will actually be cheaper
than this because the orbs are worth
money. We can sell them for 50 coins
each roughly. And uh we're actually get
some quicker crafting experience. So I
think we're going to get our crafting up
to maybe 60 uh at some point before we
uh really start investing in our other
skills. Uh, so we have some flips coming
in and I'm not really sure why, but the
book page sets have taken a while to
sell. I thought the Zamarak page would
sell quicker, but it didn't really, but
we did make still a pretty good amount
of money off that. 217K, not as much as
I thought initially, but not bad. Uh, we
also sold off the super attacks and
energies uh for another pretty decent
margin, like 8.21 21 we got the super
energy sold for and uh we bought them
for 699. So 120k there. Uh super tax for
448 558 that's 100k there. Just really
astoundingly good flips for how much
they cost. Uh so I think we're going to
straight up flip the Zamrack page three.
Uh the margin on it looks really good
and we can afford well five of them I
believe. Uh can we do five? Uh yeah we
can definitely do five. So that's the
limit. We're going to do it overnight.
So 518 and we're looking to sell those
for about 570. And we just hit another
crafting level. There's 50. I think
that's all we're going to do for now.
But uh still enjoying crafting. It's
nice AFKable ability or skill, sorry.
And we'll just bank those for now. Okay.
And another reasonably low skill that is
pretty easy to level up is my cooking.
Uh so we're just buying 1k tunas and
we're going to cook them all. Uh, we're
looking to get about 50 cooking so we
can start on lobsters. And cooking is
pretty cheap. I mean, even these tunas,
we're not going to burn that many of
them. And we'll be able to sell them for
pretty much the price we bought them
for. Unfortunately, we're never going to
have access to the cooking gauntlets,
which would be extremely helpful. But
that's okay. We'll just manually uh make
fires and cook them the good old
fashioned way. All right, there we go.
There is 40 cooking. Uh we can now
technically cook lobsters, but we're
definitely going to wait until 50 plus
uh before we start or else we're going
to burn them all. All right, there is 45
cooking. Uh we've definitely started to
burn these a lot less. Uh getting about
75k experience per hour. It should be
higher, but we're not really focusing
that much. Only five more levels and
then we can buy some lobsters. Okay
guys, there we go. There is 50 cooking.
I think that's all we're going to do for
today's episode. And uh now we can uh
cook lobsters once we get around to it.
Uh, that's also brought our total level
up quite a bit. We're definitely past
500. And also on top of that, we have
two of or all five of the Zamarak pages
sold. I think we made well, let's see.
We sold some of them for 553 and some of
them are for 545. Uh, but about 30k on
each page. So, 150k is not bad,
especially since the pages flip
reasonably quickly. Uh, so once again,
we're going to do another uh well, we're
going to do 4k potions because we're
going to bed and it's just been working
so well. I think we're going to do the
same for super attack potions. And there
we go. Another 4,000 super attack
potions. Uh again, we're leaving those
in overnight. And last up, we did the
volcanic whip mix. Um the margin on that
is not too bad. And uh just an easy use
for our money. And you can see that our
total level is over 500. Okay, so uh
we're back and I think this is where
we're going to end it for today, guys.
Uh we'll check on how much money we've
earned and our stats. Uh but first,
let's just pick up the flips. Uh so
super attacks, we sold uh all 3,000.
Mind you, we did decant it from 4,000
and the energy potions as well. Let's
have a look at that. Uh so we bought the
energy potions for 1341 and we're
selling them for
1486. 140k profit there. Uh the super
attack potions we bought for 951 and
sold for
1,097. So 150k profit there. A really
good percent return on that. Uh we have
sold some of the volcanic whip mixes.
Uh, but just for the ease of making this
a little more um well easy to understand
how much money I meant, I'm just going
to sell them. They're taking a while.
Let's see if we can instantly sell them
for there. No. Uh, if they don't drop
down a bit more, we won't bother selling
them now. But 147. And there we go. So,
we didn't really lose too much there.
And now we can see how much money we
have. Do we have any in the bank? Just a
bit. Uh, so we're looking at about 3.5
mil. Uh, which is quite a bit higher
than since the last episode, which is
awesome. Uh we have gained 504 total
levels. So over 500 uh which is awesome.
A lot of that's coming from a range
level we got to 45. The cooking levels
we got to 50. Uh crafting to 50. Uh
really nice. And uh fletching to 55. And
of course we can't forget the two
farming levels we got. Slow as
though. So hope you guys enjoyed the
series. Thank you again for all the
ongoing support. and I will see you guys
in episode six.
[Music]